hello everybody and welcome to round
table at the stream team and this is
when we talked to amazing content
creators and their journeys and what
they're doing today and how things are
progressing in their you know in their
content creator lives now we we've been
doing a lot of different people and
we've been doing people from streaming
from mixer from from strum twitch from
yo YouTube and you know all over and
today we have we have a little bit of
different paths we wanted to take with
us going to PAX East right around the
corner we wanted to start bringing our
writers from our lords of gaming to at
net website in here and today we have
and we welcome to the roundtable our
friend macho tonight how are you doing
my Cho how's things doing good doing
good thanks for having me yeah thank you
very much for coming hanging out we will
we will probably be calling you macho
we'll be calling you Hector cuz you know
what we know you we know you as both so
don't be it don't be afraid of that so
I'm happy that you know you can come
along take a little bit of time you know
you you are another vampire that i annoy
idea that you were you were on that
vampire life just like everybody else
yeah maybe you've heard or run on coffee
coffee coffee coffee and find the
computer screen all-night coffee room
the Red Bull right exactly
that's how all this guys run that's why
they call Java Java that's you know
that's what it's from so oh really
and we have we have our other other
panelists here today we have MJ as a
boss what is going on bud what's poppin
Oh things are well I'm happy that we are
gonna we're gonna you know trademark
that term I'm loving it
I want it I want to make sure we you
know stake our claim on it forever yeah
great okay thank you thanks for coming
today
thanks for taking take your time on to
it thank you and we have our lady of the
panel l-boogie how are you everybody how
you doing
however how are you things well this
week in a pretty good Monday so you know
it's it's the painful part it's like
[Music]
basically yeah we do it for all of our
Xbox games he's going to our e3 ink
conventions and things like that yeah I
used to you still don't know right if
you're gonna get out to e3
I probably won't be able to me and my
wife we're talking about taking a
vacation this year together so that will
probably take my money from e3 and that
will be thrown to that so I will
probably be sad and not be able to make
it even though this is probably one of
the best years to go so it makes me a
little sad but yeah I gotta I gotta do
what's good for the fam so for all I
know I might come down to see you one
day I'll try I'll take the train down
sounds good to me great good so we you
know why we're here why we wanted to do
was we wanted to ask our friend Hector
here macho what like why did you decide
to become a content creator why did you
decide to start writing for Lords of
gaming Don net and you know what what
like you know what drives you what's
your passion you know things like that
so once you go ahead and tell us all
these amazing things sure so I guess
like kind of like a too long didn't read
kind of vibe to this kind of like my
background here is that when I was in
college I was a gamer all my life first
and a huge Disney fan growing up so
immediately I was gravitating towards
that experience of just musicals and and
it came from my sister dollar stuffs
though that kind of like just gravitated
towards games and just the interactive
experience and it really kicked off and
I played the Kingdom Hearts for the
first time and that which is now just my
bread and butter for gaming I was like
how everybody's first video game for
them like that Malin came to games
better gear salad because it was so
cinematic that's doubles for me with
Kingdom Hearts I gotta ask you one
question well when you have you played
Kingdom Hearts lately oh yeah yeah I'm
totally up to date with everything like
did you play King have you played
Kingdom Hearts 1 well since they
remastered it and put it out yes yes yes
so I tried to I played the original also
loved it fantastic game it's one of my
favorites and I tried playing it for my
wife and I and my wife was looking at me
and she was just like how are you
playing this this is really crazy I was
like I was like alright I'm like we're
going to bed I will not play this again
with you here I was like hands hands
over and we're done
that's hilarious look because I started
playing Kingdom Hearts with my
girlfriend I think the year we started
dating and she absolutely loved it she
played the rest of them oh that's good
that's good yeah yes it's fortunate you
rolled the dice and you're happy you
were saying Disney what what come oh
yeah look I was just growing up with it
I grew up with like Aladdin Beauty and
the Beast Little Mermaid all stuff my
sisters into the Lion King
my older sister so it was just kind of
just naturally was a part of my life
mm-hm and in college I was going for
criminal justice degree in criminal
justice and then one day I'll just say I
can't do this anymore I was so bored
with it that I decided to move towards
content creation whether it be video
writing so ever since then which is
about like me five or six years ago I
just started working and building my
resume towards that and one thing led to
another where I start writing for the
one-wheel podcasts when they had the
website up mm-hmm
that led to me getting my graduate
degree in journalism and digital media
then I started working for Comic Book
Resources I'm a freelance writer there
currently and then Eric cuts for the
wind was a YouTube no need to write on a
crumb side of here she told me about
Lords of gaming and introduced me to COG
and everybody else and then I applied
and it's been smooth sailing from there
it's been nothing but great things with
with everybody having so welcomed by the
by the locknut community its it's been
unreal and I'm totally grateful for
everything so what would you say is your
your favorite part about the
it's a gaming community right now it's
definitely just the community feeling
about it because there's certain
communities all part of even the Kingdom
Hearts community to some degree or just
felt like everybody was kind of distant
from each other and you are the internet
friend but when it came to lagna it felt
way more than just your my internet
friend like we were actually we're
actually cool like we're we're part of
this grand not plan but just again this
grand part of grant group just that
we're all working together and we're all
of the same things so why not make the
best of what we can do with it with it
you know so would you would you say that
it's almost like what sort of look for
kinda like you have support like you're
you're like if you need something and
you can't get to it you can ask like we
oh yeah definitely
good no I know that like MJ and myself
we both we both right for for locknut
and I mean MJ you would you'd agree
right like you have this amazing support
system yeah and like if I know that if I
have a problem with Oracle or if I'm
reading an article and I'm like always
help yeah I'm like I can't get this
correctly done Cod can you do it or I'll
send it off and be like yo diz I was
like I got this article it's I think
it's done but a Mike this paragraph
sounds wrong can you can you look over
it or ask on dad or or froster and those
guys are there they're like a huge
support to you know kind of help push us
to to you know what what what's right
what's good and what you know looks
right on paper yeah it's it's it's been
a blessing like I said it's just you
know from the get-go and all about
support and no matter what they they
focus on your voice and what you want to
say while also adhering to quality
because they do want good stuff on the
website right you want the
representation and that's so the most I
can do is bring out the quality content
for them if they're willing to support
my voice and they've been more than
willing so I've been extremely grateful
about that
yeah so you were saying before that you
do different types of content creation
what other do you do any other type of
content creation other than just the the
writing portion for for laug net or
another another website or anything like
that well yeah I do write freelance for
comic book resources it's it's the same
kind of not writing style I guess it's
the same kind of thing when it comes to
like net where you're writing about
entertainment
it's a comic resource for small more
gambit of things like movies television
comics video games stuff like that and I
also for my full-time job I work for my
local news station so I go to work and I
literally write my content that's base
from the disc at the broadcast in the
show's mm-hmm so I just take everything
that they say on the air and I put it
into a nice web format so that people
can read it online yeah yeah it's it's
it's it's hard work but it's worth it
because you learn you know all the nooks
and crannies when it comes to efficient
writing and what's include what not to
include so it's good and it just it's
what I'd love to do which is writing and
this is where I wanted to be so I'm
looking towards the next step obviously
I'm gonna see going more to
entertainment medium with video games or
movies but right now it's a great start
what would you what would you say is
kind of like your dream you're like I'm
talking like being being like a writer
like working where would you want to
project yourself like writing novels
little write writing just like the news
articles for websites or what do you
think yeah so one of my things I always
want to do is to write a book go out to
fantasy because I love the fantasy genre
when it comes to just reading so I
always want to dabble into that and one
day I would definitely publish my own
book as far as like a dream job it's
always been to work for Disney and
Disney World so it's definitely or the
Disney movie studios unlike the
promotional side or working on a movie
itself writing a movie or even if it and
the
inside - love to do that just to be part
of like the social media or the public
relations marketing kind of thing I just
love writing a love video I love making
videos - so anything when it comes it's
that kind of creativity I'm all for yeah
so a couple couple little cool tidbits
if you ever think you're gonna want to
write a book right and you think man
it's it's it's so far beyond my reach
it's never gonna be something that I'll
be able to achieve I have a nice long
commute I have about an hour to an
hour-and-a-half commute from from where
I live into into close to the city and
what ends up happening is like your mind
wanders and you kind of think of things
and this and that the other thing and I
sort of getting these ideas for for a
book so I actually started like jotting
down my ideas of what I wanted to do
produce a plot and all that other stuff
and I actually ended up over the course
of about three months I produced the
plot for a book and uh for just from
driving back and forth to work and I'm
not talking about like full underwriting
I'm just talking about like ideas so
what I ended up doing from there is I
started taking my hour-long lunch and I
started like plugging away at it and
before before I knew it I actually have
a 350 page book Dantan to the point
where I just need my my amazing wife
who's an amazing content reader she
reads a lot of books to go through it
edit it so that I can kind of go over it
and see where we go with it but it shows
that even if you have a little bit of an
idea or a little bit of a want you can
always find a little bit of time to
figure out what you're gonna do with it
and if that's something you dream of
doing that is something that you know
you can do you just gotta you know make
it make a little time for it and then
you kind of like nibble away at it and
then eventually you love it done so it's
right yeah III you know I I support you
in that and I want you to you know I
want you to be able to you know tell me
you know eventually hey I'm done with
this thing and I want I want to see it
because those are the things
when people are passionate about things
they'll make time for them and it seems
like you're do that with with all your
articles because I've read multiple ones
of your articles and they're great and
the just something I thought my head was
the the picture that you sent me that
I'm gonna put as that your thumbnail was
that and was it called distant worlds
the oh no that was it um the world of
trace or christopher kingdom arts oh
okay mm-hmm that's a second video game
concert I went to well yeah one of two
or the second one being the only of two
which is both Kingdom Hearts concerts
mm-hmm um have you gone to like the
Broadway shows and stuff because you're
your connecticut-based right yeah yeah
so yeah I mean I haven't gone as much as
I would like to UM but last I once was
to see come from away with went with my
girlfriend and it's based on the the
flights that went to I think a little
town like yeah I know I'm blanking on
like the actual story details but it was
basically after 9/11 when all the
flights had to be redirected to
somewhere else and how the little town
kind of like pitched in and to make sure
everyone's safe and all that stuff it's
a good show that's good good did you
have use have you seen the Disney shows
yes
yeah actually took my girlfriend to go
see like ink that's her favorite movie
yeah oh my god Jose did you go over hide
everything were you an orchestra or you
up top in the balcony I went for a
balcony for the first sound like just so
that she can see cuz you mean if you
have you seen it before I I have see
I've seen I I've seen the bunch of
Broadway shows back in my back of my
college days let me get my Walker and
you know like my wife and I we we try to
make this plan to go every year now at
least to go to one but I used to go to a
lot and I saw a lion king back in I
think 2003 2004
yeah it's asking yeah it was great
that I was supposed to do a Harry Potter
thing you told me about Harry Potter so
it sounds like especially the three of
us need to just go to Disney World I
mean like it's only a 12 hour drive from
here and like I used to live in Altadena
which is only 45 minutes from a
Disneyland so I used to go like every
other weekend and haven't been in the
going forever and it's sad you gotta go
do that real special time and because we
know girl from went last year with it
was awesome
what's the best time well we went during
March because of that's when she was
finishing up with school mm-hmm it
wasn't crazy though for Spring Break
it wasn't it wasn't that crazy because
she her spring break was a little a week
after everybody else's Spring Break well
you know like during the whole month of
March basically somebody is on spring
break
mm-hmm cuz I know that for him is Neil
and like just that whole month of March
he just didn't want to go because all
the little kids were out and there it
was made right okay and we went when all
the kids were finishing school yeah yep
it's so bad oh they'll give you don't
get me wrong like half the time were
playing dodge the kid stroller but other
than that it was actually pretty good it
wasn't that bad
he's gonna he's gonna push him out of
the way oh yeah yeah as he knows like
you're from phonetic hearing in New York
you just learned how to walk in crowds
I just rush through everybody yeah so we
can't adapt that to Florida and we're
just like going through like every
little space we could find just to get
ready to get to okay so I don't know if
I ever told you guys but like we went
one year
for gay days it's like an unofficial day
but gay days at Disneyland and I
basically put the date in my calendar so
that I would never go again because it
was just a bunch of people who hate
children
and Disneyland I was just like I cannot
believe you all took over the park and
you hate children
like why here why are you here like you
can't hate kids of being like I don't
get the audacity MJ is just like I
started tricular gourmet ramen cuz you
know adults I don't think that stuff is
actually pretty good
gourmet ramen so it's like literally a
chef it was like okay I'm gonna make
ramen noodles and then I put the ramen
noodles together with spices and stuff
it's not like company like in a
restaurant or like it's it's like at the
grocery store so like the grocery store
has actual like ramen just like like the
cup of noodles which is essentially the
college version of ramen this is like
the legit ramen like this is like good
ramen like it has like good noodles in
it like fresh this and fresh that and
and everything's all together it's
actually pretty good it's actually not
that bad for you I was just I was like
huh the salt content is actually doable
some pictures I mean it's but it's like
there's like two books up like a
container I'm just like alright this is
good I'll eat this this is quick and
easy for me so um so breathe breathe
let's bring this back as you change it
once again so we I know that you might
you me who else is going King Kong shaft
and Bob I think it is I think we're all
the ones that are going up to pax this
year firm force I think right I think so
yes a handful people so how do
how did you feel like when you when you
told the guys hey I'm coming passing you
guys I'm excited to go it's like to
interview people and talk like like what
was like your big highlight of like I'm
excited to do this moment when would
that happen like the anticipation type
thing well at first I was initially
hesitant uh because when they're
bringing it up but wasn't sure because
there's only like a couple months as
I've been with Lords of gaming so I
wasn't really sure how to feel these
guys out um already think of that nature
but I decided just to take the dive for
it because opportunity I just could not
give up so I decided to go for it and
then when everything is official and you
know we're you know getting our rooms
and everything else it really started
settled in like the beginning of January
I don't like this year is really gonna
be awesome
because I get to start by going to pax
and talking to game developers doing all
the sort all the stuff that I've been
wanting to do for years at this point
right why I decide to change my my
college degree and go with digital media
and journalism stead of just criminal
justice it's it's all been leading to
this and it's like the first step this
one that the first stone to cast in the
water then man it's it's awesome
again I'm super super excited just to
finally get in there and talk to
developers and mm-hmm
like about their passion in in the game
that they've been working so hard on and
just to tell other people about it it's
it's cool it's really really cool it's
it's really you'll see when you go and
like MJ it was him myself in cog we were
actually the team one team last year and
from from walking up to a developer and
asking him those questions you you you
almost like feel it like you feel the
essence coming off them you're gonna
absolutely you know be in love with it
MJ what like what was your what was your
like you know top moment like when we
went last year walk around to people
talking to people um probably just
getting to know the developers one on
one yeah and getting to play stuff early
and having them like the actual
developer talk you through how to play
it instead of like you know what a man
instead of like
in line and not having somebody who made
the game help you guide you through yeah
it's it's it's it's really amazing and I
know that like one of the games that
kind of like stood out in my brain last
year and that's earlier messenger was
great with with those guys and we'll
probably end up seeing them again this
year but I was going to say meeting the
guys that made Streets of Rage oh yes
HF Age that was so that was that was one
of one of my favorite moments of patsies
last year and it wasn't the fact that
like MJ got whooped like in the first
five minutes of the game and looked over
to cog and I go cog how far you want me
to go with this and he's like beat the
level and I'll let you and I instantly
put my game face on and you're like game
face on
and then you like kind of like power
through like when you know did you ever
play like the old like Streets of Rage
or anything like that made no I did not
know I figured you have Hector how about
you know I know oh my god it's their
side scrollers kind of like you know
little dragons and things like that and
I'm I know like I know Ella's probably
played similar games to that side
scrollers right yeah the side scroller
type games yeah I remember it Streets of
Rage I can't remember like I don't think
that that was anything that I played
like consistently yeah yeah so like I
put my face on and I beat the level and
like cogs just like screaming and
yelling it's so excited it was just like
crazy and the developers were kind of
like a little like confused like how did
this happen and then like we go outside
and we started talking to him and we
kind of showed them what was going on
like what we were all about and you felt
the passion that these guys brought
because they literally brought this Dead
franchise back to life and hopefully
hopefully we get to go see those guys
and you can kind of meet them and and
its really awesome and then Kingdom Come
deliverance guys are going to be there
this is this year we're actually
supposed to to those guys and we're
gonna probably be seeing them and it's
it's
it's got great feeling and I'm happy
that you know you can come and kind of
see that and enjoy it with us and the
the the Lord's are game inside for the
for the website now uh are you gonna are
you gonna try to like you know write
more articles for them for like packs or
of just specific content or what do you
think your your plan is for that
well I we haven't really talked too much
about like I gotta play avataq Kitsch
because we're getting a lot of the press
mm-hmm emails right now of I mean the
idea had my head was baby there's a lot
of really great prayer panels going on
that could be really cool to be a part
of and just witness and may if I if I
pulled the press card because big an
interview with like a panelist or
there's something when it comes to games
may be doing doing like a special story
piece when it comes to this developers
game because one of the stories always
interested me that came from from sites
like for instance Katoch without tell
not only tell why this games special but
it'll tell a story behind why it's
special mm-hmm such as maybe it's a
localization issue or something I
overcome and I want to see if I can look
for something like that if I can find
that one story that can tell a really
really great and inspiring story about a
game developer and their game coming out
I'll be happy that's that's really nice
it's something that's something I like
you know we'll have to keep an eye out
for and something because I never I
never actually thought of something like
that I never thought of I don't know
going to panel seeing seen those
developers and communicating with them
and talk to them I never I never thought
of that
I I have one friend who she does
she works for a not-for-profit for
disabled bro she produces Braille dies
she makes them literally on 3d printer
in her house and I saw her last year on
one of the panels with her with other
people that had you know over different
disabilities and meeting them and
talking to those guys was they'll have
amazing
stories and I never thought of trying to
communicate with them with fake you know
that develop in stead of it being that
being developers and trying to get
background stories it's really it's
really a nice in-depth thought
conversation for that that's really cool
that's good thank you thank you yeah I
mean it's it's again I just love stories
I love telling stories so that kind of
adds to that as well as saying well this
game is cool and that game is awesome I
think there's a lot more to it than just
promoting other games or saying why this
games really cool it's there's a lot of
stories to be told behind behind the
curtain and I think as writers and as
people were super passionate about this
industry we kind of have an obligation
to tell those stories right a lot of
them been telling about crunch and
though in the workforce which is all
important stuff and only the things that
I want to highlight was diversity in
gaming there's not like a whole lot of
it so I kind of want to break the mold
on that and see we can do and what the
pants actually at PAX is I think it's
called um it's it's something lines of
like ethnic developers and disappointing
your parents or something like that
which is something I'm really
interesting because I'd say like my
parents disappointed like my career
choice they always been supporting me
but there's always expectation and my
family at least since I'm Hispanic is
that there is always like to reach for
the doctor or boy or something like that
I was always kind of a highlight growing
up but yeah that's that's not what I
what to do is so my passion so how did
your parents feel when you decided that
you were in change from criminal justice
to you know media media journalism I was
fairly surprised by they were fully
supportive of it I was a junior when I
told them that I was not happy with what
I was doing and I want to go I basically
told my that what would work for Disney
I want to go right I want to do that and
then there just looked at me like well
you got a lot to do but so go do it yeah
and it was kind of just a wrap from
there so they I just left it in my hands
and ever since then it's been the way it
is now so I've been fully supported by
them and everybody else it's been a
blessing yeah that's
it's really that's really great that's
it's good to have you know that that's
supporting that and that backing to be
able to you know be able to want your
dreams to come true so it's really good
for sure yeah yeah they're without them
I wouldn't be where I am today so yeah
are you are you planning to go to any
other conventions other than PAX East
this year or not not in this not really
just because uh pax is one of the ones
that I just kind of like out of nowhere
and there's I do it just to do it just
get those opportunities put I've to
Disney trip with my girl and a couple
other plans that got going on this year
so I had to take a little bit on the
lighter side um school loans kills me
when it comes my paycheck so I gotta be
careful with that
Oh school loans yeah never it's it's
it's a killer for sure yeah as as L
would say try to make it to III I mean
yeah just go to Disneyland and hit a 3
to see that see that you my annual pass
expires like at the end of June 2 so I'm
just like well I'm definitely going to
either either and so that I can go to
Disneyland one when is III it's like the
six to the 11th something like that of
June yeah yeah I don't think he's gonna
although he should I might is it
expensive probably is yes at least it's
like one it's 152 yeah bottles my mind
about Disney the way that they do their
ticket pricing is like if you're gonna
buy a ticket and you're gonna get like
three days the price of the tickets like
diminish over time so like your first
day will be a hundred bucks the next day
will be like 80 bucks so I'm actually
after that'll be a 60 bucks so it's like
each day
diminishes so that the price is cheaper
well because I'm you know military I can
get military tickets so they're a lot
cheaper so I can get like I think before
I left it was like 188 for 4 days and
you didn't have to use it's four days
consecutively and you only had a block
out like during Christmas so but why
would you want to go during Christmas
because it's the best I'm talking about
like just during Christmas or when they
put the winter lights up right so
Christmas
oh so it's going to be from the end of
November well no no you have like like
that week of Christmas you can't go like
what those tickets but I don't know like
being in California like if you live in
California you really don't get that
type of like Christmas spirit unless
you're at Disneyland like it's not
snowing outside it's [ __ ] 80 degrees
so if you want it to feel like Christmas
you're going to Disneyland Knott's Berry
Farm or something
are you saying that you haven't gotten
any snow yet yes I'm very sad we haven't
snow yet we haven't gotten snow either
oh no that's why we got snow like once
we got snow once this year so far and
it's it was like gone within hours but
it's been for raising it has been pretty
bad up here yeah yeah I have like super
cold days and no snow like I wake up and
it's like 17 degrees outside
it was 55 today I was like what the heck
is this you know 70 here today oh my god
shorts weather yeah but yeah so did you
know Hector did you end up like
producing like a YouTube page or I had
yeah you do so yeah what'd I say that I
was lying to my girlfriend about this
earlier where she are you gonna talk
about YouTube hey I don't like I don't
know about that it's because like the
thing is when I started I started
YouTube on one channel and then a whole
bunch of embarrassing videos later start
one more embarrassing videos where to
and I just used it mostly as like a kind
of like a side thing for when I was in
graduate school just for video projects
mm-hmm
I swear every time I bring it up my
girlfriend brings up that one stream I
did where I was feeling really nice and
tipsy and playing overwatch and there's
a lot of dancing involved so you end up
streaming and then putting it on there
or ever you just just tape yeah yeah I
know i streamed me the ps4 and then you
know it just it's end up on the it's on
the YouTube page right now I haven't
deleted it's a nice little fun callback
oh you say that this band knows how to
dance that's all I get a good Friday
that's a good Friday my dancing skills
that's great so what was like the first
memory you have of you know of gaming of
like you know sitting next to you like a
family member
playing a game to like wall-to-wall on
TV you actually for a while the earliest
like your earliest one like do you
remember like sitting playing like you
know Mario we think your brother or like
or your sister or something or like you
know or like your dad's kind of like no
you gotta trip over that like kind of
like that yeah yeah so I don't know I
don't know which came first but was lots
of my cousin's over their house or they
had a ps1 and will always play spyro why
are you the dragon and ape escape those
are two games were just like okay yeah
these are fun they're really cool
another cousin playing Crash Bandicoot
and that was just hard as hell I don't
think he ever finished it it was just so
hard
and yeah the supplies like probably the
earliest game in it and then when I got
my own ps1 you you know cousin play
Crazy Taxi and
I'll always play this little disc called
GM pack which was just a disc full of
demos on it and this one had everything
from like snowboarding to Spyro to
spider-man and I play that constantly
since I didn't have money grow you know
I didn't have money myself because too
young and my parents weren't really they
weren't really like oh let's get him a
game every now and then I just kind of I
was very simple when I came to my gaming
takes back then back when back in the
day when you used to buy you know like
PC gamer magazines they used to throw
that like the demo desk is that what
you're talking about yeah yeah something
like that I don't remember what magazine
it was but uh it was just a little disc
called JM pack and I'm gonna had a whole
bunch of demos Monday that was like the
one thing I would go to Sierra take off
from school yeah they was a cold day
like I remember getting those discs for
PC and then popping them in I like
playing a whole bunch of games on them
and I was just like this is awesome this
is great like this is like it was like
you got like the option to play all the
different games and now you can
essentially just get game paths and do
the same thing which is an amazing thing
yeah yeah it wasn't until I walked into
a blockbuster and I saw their place of
all the ps1 rentals with ps2 games and I
was like alright something's got changed
here
I got an ax for ps2 and then now the
same your Kingdom Hearts came out so
that's when I kind of kicked off the era
I was like wow gaming is a lot more than
just levels and funny characters and
there's actually there's actually a good
wait for to tell narratives yeah I think
that narrative games like I I felt like
when the regular Nintendo was out it had
the ability to produce a really good
like there's a couple of games that had
really good narratives storylines for
instance you know like the Final Fantasy
games that's what they're known for like
their storylines
those are the ones that really stand out
for me and then going to like Sega
Genesis I mean there really was maybe a
handful of JRPGs but they I didn't feel
like they didn't really come into their
own
until PlayStation 2 hit until like
actual full-fledged stories like it was
just nice because now I feel that more
games are story driven and have
background and they get you invested
yeah for sure you're sure that's what um
that's again that's what kind of like
led me to be like all right game is a
little more than just you know all of
these levels in twenty characters or
something and again like you're saving
for with Final Fantasy for sure like I
remember I played Kingdom Hearts that's
all fancy characters in it so
immediately I was already interested in
Final Fantasy from the start and that's
why I actually started playing the games
for them and even even though they're
around the towns playing them maybe like
ten twelve years old around the time
maybe my how old these games were but
something is like five fancy seven and
six and eight and you know all the ones
from there and it was like oh my god
like this started way before I even
thought like these games were more than
just what they were yeah where this I
played them so it's it's absolutely
mind-blowing what you can achieve in the
video game when it comes to narrative
based storytelling and never making some
amazing strides with it yeah yeah it's
really it's really really interesting um
MJ do you happen to have any questions I
did not he basically asked answer the
question that I had but yeah which was
your question you know basically like
how he like decided that he wanted to do
go into writing and whatnot and we had
our Disney talk and stuff so you have to
ask you so have you okay so have you
been - what's when's the last time you
were at Disney World I guess marched
19 okay so the Star Wars stuff was open
right no they actually opened up at the
end of August I want to say yeah so we
totally missed that on that but it was
lost to my first my girlfriends sort of
her first time going to Disney World it
was the first time really exploring
everything so we kind of just hit the
gambit like every park and well how many
days would you stay
I can do my whole Disney flips we stay
for seven days at once
okay so I've heard that you're not
supposed to try to go to like everything
even within seven days so did you guys
get on certain things well I didn't
think to when we started planning it I
was like we can't hit everything because
it to be too exhausting mm-hmm thank you
much but uh but I'd surprise her with
the ticket to Hollywood studios just say
like alright it's really that's really
cap it off so we we planned accordingly
we didn't like go to we didn't spend an
entire day at one park unless we had
energy for it might go in the morning
it's more a little bit get something to
eat come back hotel take a nap and go
back at nights or simply want to see
more of okay yeah so we had a whole game
thing going with it but it was
definitely a little stretching it so the
next disney trip we're going on which is
actually this year christmas time yeah
we're living to like to parks and that's
the so far it's Magic Kingdom at Epcot
and we're just gonna take our time
exploring that within four or five days
okay so last question about Disney World
though guys where do you guys stay like
we say that the I think is the art of
art of all no not that one it was the
one those face on films I think move use
all-star movies or estimates all-star
movie Resort is that Disney Resort it is
it's it's pretty close okay yeah yeah
yeah it's I think it's near
see it's right but it's right by the
beach caribbean beach resort it's like
right in the center it's it's it's
pretty centered to everything okay yeah
yes it's not bad position was that not
bad at all I there heard some horror
stories it's the translation around
Disney parks bill wasn't that bad yeah I
was just wondering cuz I know that when
I look at like I stayed at the Grand
Californian Hotel for like one night and
it was like $700 so when I when I went
with my a bunch of my like two of my
really close friends back in I'm gonna
say oh nine it was before before I met
my wife we stayed at the the Polynesian
for seven days and it was way too much
money then it should have been well I
will tell you that the the quality was
crazy it's just like their cruise line
and everything else like you you're like
that's $700 was like a lot but that was
probably the most amazing hotel I've
ever stayed in yeah it's it's nice I
told everybody I was like if you're
gonna do it I was staying at the
Polynesian was probably one of the
smartest things we could do because when
we left the Magic Kingdom we ended up
taking a boat directly to the Polynesian
so we didn't have to take trams we
didn't have to take any we didn't have
to go through a million different lines
right nobody there we just hopped on the
we hopped on the boat ferry and we were
just there it was great that's cool
that's super cool
it was definitely nice yeah I would
definitely think about getting a little
more high early cold hotel stay this
time around since we are saying for
Alyssa days and I saved up a good amount
of money just just for that and at the
same time I have a friend that works at
Disney growth so she's able to hook me
up with a little bit of a discount for
the hotels and stuff like that which is
always nice yeah oh well so I got a
couple of things so I gotta tell you
later
hahaha after after we're done after
we're done recording
yes that's I'm sorry oh go ahead Jim or
no that's it the whole time I could tell
it you hit the three of us will see here
talking about Disney and MJ's just
sitting there going I got my beer I'm
good so so one quick final question but
I think I think you already you probably
already know what the answer we already
know what the answer is and as MJ
pointed out G feel decided to steal this
question from us that was pretty funny
when you when you texted me that so if
you could live in one video game fantasy
environment what would it be
that's a tough one
wow that's really tough I thought you
were gonna be like ah the world of
Kingdom Hearts I thought you're gonna be
something like that I would but there's
so much drama there and play I just
watch oh man I mean one of the things
that first came to mind would wow I
don't even know to be a fifty because
it's like there's so many like great
world set I could just be a part of and
ha that's a tough one
dude probably right probably actually I
think about it now I'm looking at my
game yourself probably Massa on our
world it'd be pretty bad has to be a
boxer hunter is that a source why is
that is that like your top game right
now that you've been playing no actually
uh I mean Monster Worlds was my game of
the year when it came out and it's
amazing but right now the game up
playing and that's just been taking over
my life it's been five fantasy xiv yeah
it's I love 14th grade I played it for
many years and I only I only started to
lose being able to play it because I
just didn't have time and that's like
right one storm blood like I'm halfway
through the storm blood story and I kind
of just started petering off but I've
you know I've
watched a couple of people playing them
and seeing the combat and I say it's
probably the best MMO out right now and
I think people it's a very underrated
game and people should definitely if
you're playing mmo's you know I would
not be playing like WoW or anything like
that
even though i do play wow because my
friends want me to play wow but but yeah
Final Fantasy 14 is great oh yeah and
it's another one of those games with an
amazing story behind it and I think
about it yeah actually because I'm
looking at my physical gaming shop I'm
just like let me see what catches from
there but yeah 5 it's 14 I would choose
is like the world to live in that world
is absolutely beautiful and it's amazing
date done with that are you gonna fly
Joker boo oh yeah oh yeah by behemoth I
love buying the beat units in that game
just like yes this is my friend going
around flying around it's cool so why
don't you tell everybody where they can
find you yeah sure so um actually are
you still there tell you there I'm here
do we just lose sector thanks no
internet I thought was my own or not I'm
Jay alright he's been acting weird the
whole house is off right now the right
of reason this is still going so I'm J
either yeah in there why don't we why
don't we do our enjoy we do our intros
our outros while we're waiting for her
to come back alright you can find me on
snapchat at beat 101 on Twitch at MJ's a
boss and then Twitter at bay TMJ and he
is popping all the time on there yep l
what about you alright you can find me
Tuesday through Friday on mixer 7 p.m.
Eastern to about 10 and it's at LBL 208
and on Twitter the same LBO 208 and then
you can find me Saturday mornings on the
Roma gaming podcast at 9:00 a.m.
West Coast time 12:00 p.m. Eastern and
then this Sunday all the ladies have
grown the gaming will be on iron Lords
podcast oh that's gonna be fun I didn't
get disconnected oh you did it was
really like you were the only one so it
was a weird weird Luvdisc action you had
oh that's so so L you so all the ladies
are there on Sunday you guys everyone
should definitely definitely go check
out out and everyone make sure you're
checking out their podcast on Saturdays
I I don't catch it live but I've been
checking it on Mondays it's usually what
I have playing in the background while
I'm doing my work good show yeah check
it out I'll check it out because uh I
commute to work too so I need some
podcasts listen to definitely definitely
Hector when you tell us all your
information where we can find you we end
up losing you right while you write when
you started talking okay I bet yes so
you guys I'm mostly active on Twitter
where it's where I just shout out my
articles and LinkedIn page any career
opportunities so you guys can follow me
at twitter at hector underscore ram
capital i I and yeah just for me on
there for all my content while my law
firm pages for loads of gaming and CBR
and that's network it's have some fun
man I love I love talking to you I love
meeting new people so let's set it up
there you go and that's where you can
find that's where you can find our buddy
macho so and I am I am snow though SN al
why do I am on Twitter discord Facebook
not Facebook I do that every time
twitch Monday to Friday 7:00 to 10:00
sometimes later and popping up randomly
on the weekends check my Twitter when I
do go live I greatly appreciate you guys
for coming and hanging out and talking
and
and being able to listen to our podcast
I'm sorry for it not being live my
internet has been wonky so I'm that's
why we are live now you know you could
put this recording up so we can you know
all this into it later you know like I
was saying that it will go up on iTunes
on to on on Tuesday I'm sorry on
Wednesday I am totally screwed up today
it's gonna be going up on iTunes Spotify
all those fun places on Wednesday so we
will have that there if you have any
questions or anything for any of the
people that are on the shows please
email us at around table stream team at
gmail.com our Twitter page is table
stream go ahead and check us out there
when you can see who's coming live and
what's gonna be going on so you guys
know as everyone knows Ireland's podcast
is on Sundays at I want to say one my
brains so integrated with it being at
11:00 but it's at 1:00 now right I think
so yeah yeah I think so they have it on
the website
yeah I'm losing my mind yeah I need some
caffeine and and and make sure everyone
checks out Lloyd's argument at net for
our news and gaming articles from many
of our panelists and a lot of our
friends out there so please make sure
you guys check that out and remember
everyone to dream big and keep gaming
and we will talk to everybody next week
and we'll see you later
alright everybody thank you very much
and have a great week everybody